j'ai dit la drogue et la cocaïne ça te
tuera et quand je disais ça et l'alcool
il me regardait d'ailleurs de dire oui
mais une fois on était sorti et il était
dans un état
un peu déplorable et je me suis dit
heureusement en effet qui conduit pas à
ce moment-là on est rentré en taxi c'est
vrai qu'on s'est lié plus d'amitié de il
y a une passion qui est née pendant
voilà d'être tombe amoureux de lui
amoureux je dirais pas amoureux mais on
a eu vraiment
on se confiait l'un à l'autre et je ne
veux absolument pas accuser Pierre
Palmade j'étais aussi conscient de ce
que je faisais mais c'est vrai que
en le côtoyant je suis tombé dans
certains excès c'est quoi les excès
c'est que c'est c'était plus d'alcool
c'était à toucher essayer la cocaïne la
vieille j'avais touché
pas mal de substances n'étaient plus
mettre forcément de lui-même et ça c'est
quelque chose en effet qui me faisait
peur aussi